just some of the possible winners for
this year's games boss 2014 game of the
year as I said all games are released
this year are eligible we have a lengthy
discussion talking about who our
platform winners were who our game of
the month winners were and a
free-for-all where I'm looking forward
to seeing who comes out the winner we
won't be announcing the winner for a
week and a half but right off the bat
some fantastic games that came out this
year
let's go back to earlier in the year
Bayonetta 2 a game that got 10 out of 10
on GameSpot the first time attended a
number of years and the highest reviews
are high scored game on game this year
at Kevin what is it about bayonetta 2
everything makes us eligible for a
possible game with you that game is so
good it is what makes it eligible it's
just I would say that maybe from a
mechanical perspective it is probably
the most mechanically perfect action
game to ever be me and I did except for
the fact that I wish it was a little
harder the first time through our normal
difficulty that's the only real gameplay
problem I had with it I just think this
game is exquisite in every way and
playing it means having a giant grin on
your face
from beginning and I finished it in an
eyetie it was just a seven hour stretch
where I started and finished it and I
never stopped laughing and smiling I
just love this game and let's keep it on
the WiiU let's talk about in a game that
a lot of people have enjoyed this year
and maybe not so fervently but it has a
sort of a mass appeal to it Mario Kart 8
it's a game that I've been playing a lot
in my bed's this week since I got a Wii
last week and have you know realised the
wonders of just sitting in your bed with
the gamepad and then realizing 3:00 in
the morning I'm gonna say people do get
pretty passionate about mario karta but
then you brought this whole bed thing
probably still holds true I mean you
know you're like again you hear Kevin
talk about bayonetta and having a smile
on your face I feel like if you don't
have a smile on your face in Mario Kart
you're just enraged because someone has
just like shelled you or done something
and like beneath that rage is a smile
because the games are Specter game is so
fun the track design is so good and it's
just
feels so good to play it's one of these
games that just feels great and I want
to give a shout out to another game
which a bunch of people in the office
are determines that it is at least their
favorite game of 2014 whether or not it
is game spots we'll just have to wait
and see the dark below it's just commish
half the office is back home playing
destiny you want to talk about
contentious conversations yeah we have
during the discussion right here no and
then we have people going to bat because
they are have played it literally like
every week almost every day since they
came out and just are so into the grind
into the PvP into the PvE into the raid
into the gear into like their alt
characters into this world and you know
there are some legit shots you can take
a destiny for sure but I that hasn't
stopped it from remaining such a
highlight of the year for so many
fantastic game and divisive and I think
it would be very interesting to see
where that comes from because it can't
just giggling to himself here and what's
up of Kevin shaking his mattering six
point eight hundred breath and let's
talk about a game actually that maybe
you weren't too hot on as well the some
other foul or which was a far cry for
another game which could possibly win
this is I totally get it Mike I mean
even with destiny I totally get it
that's the thing I might shake my head
but I do get it and with far cry I get
it as well it's just such a great that
Ubisoft formula that they've really
honed for the open-world I mean it's
easy to roll our eyes and I do often
about the Ubisoft formula but when it
comes down to it it works because it
eats you chasing one activity over the
other and in the times in between the
things that you chase is actually where
the adventure happens yeah if that makes
sense and so you might be chasing a
little dot on a map but actually what
you're doing is you're just you're just
mapping a route from here to there
knowing that the cool stuff is what
happens in between and I want to have a
quick little thought as well about some
games that haven't been mentioned in our
nominees list but are still eligible two
of the other Ubisoft games that came out
this year that use that system Kevin I'd
like to speak to you again Assassin's
Creed unity and watchdogs these could
possibly be game of the Year winners
I mean you never know um you know I
actually really liked watch dogs but I
actually like watch dogs in part because
even though it's story wasn't that great
some of its themes really spoke to me
themes of of pee packing people's no it
was more about the idea of people so
invested in this life right looking at
their phone that they forgot to be
invested in this flight that's the part
that really spoke to me and I actually
think that's a theme what are you doing
what sorry keV oh look yeah why are we
giving the winner to cross the road
what's going on can we talk no yeah true
cross the road is technically eligible
you can play as a pigeon that poops as
it walks so wait this is just flappy
bird on the euro road you can play as a
pigeon that can poop in gta5 as well
you can't I had the reason all you need
to do is take drugs are you thinking of
the rig's as a human that poops well
they want
I don't think okay game a game that's
real life in the world lots of great
open-world games that come out this year
of course and one of the ones that I
think took a lot of people by surprise
couple of months ago was Midler shadow
of Mordor Alexey you've been a lot of
this game I've played the heck out of
that game it's just so big and like you
don't have to look I spent maybe before
six or seven hours of my playthrough not
playing any story missions I just wanted
to go after those arcs and then which
then you come down and the game does a
really good job of making you care about
all of that side stuff because that side
stuff just makes you more powerful you
can unlock runes for your sword make
your sword more power for make you more
powerful and then you're you know uber
powerful then you can go take them he's
working see let's keep it real the
reason you actually went around and did
all that stuff is because you were tired
if it works mom mouthing off to you and
you just wanted to kill them all perhaps
I don't know please let me talk about
that for a second to like me I think
that these enemies are all very smartly
written to some of the dialogues really
funny yeah these orcs a different
personalities I'm having somebody you
know an orc that you thought you'd
killed and a couple of eras earlier come
up with a big metal place and
head screaming at you calling out
exactly what happened is that something
really good yeah it's you know I think
the thing about Mordor is that you sort
of forget when you're playing it just
how more interesting it is than most
third-person action games the things
that it nails it gets combat it gets
exploration the side quests are
interesting the Nemesis system of course
is fantastic but there haven't been that
many third-person action games that have
really been that interesting one game
for instance that we haven't seen come
up in our nominees yeah which is also
still a chable of course is infamous
second song that's again what do you got
it but you exactly you put that up
against Mordor you sort of you realize
wow Mordor actually does quite a lot
very well and another game that does in
a sort of traditional genres a war is
Dragon Age Inquisition
yeah I want to talk about like enemies
having personality in Mordor and then
giving the world personality Dragon Age
Inquisition is you know as a Bioware
game it's the personalities of your
party members that really I think draws
with me into this and the cheered like
this is a game where every mission for
me is like almost like a Sophie's Choice
of like I can't you're really cool I
want to take the pool I want to hear
what you have to say to this person's I
want to take me with a pair but I only
can bring three people at a time like
but just I spend you know as much time
out exploring the world as wandering
around Haven striking up conversations
with these people because their
personality is such an interesting part
of the game and it's such a rewarding
aspect to explore as speaking of
difficult decisions another fantastic
role-playing game that came out on PC
but from a different perspective
divinity original sin oh yeah you're a
big fan of this one Kevin yeah I am and
and again I think that we can talk about
Bioware games in which the decisions
sort of come down to two story branches
or a game like divinity where the
decisions come down to just it's it's
very procedural in this case and so what
you do it's not just a matter of do I do
I try to talk or do I try to fight you
try to talk what kind of talking are you
going to do I mean it really comes down
to stuff like that and if you and if you
decide to fight you might miss out on on
completely new quests because because of
that alone you know there's things like
hey you can talk to animals but you may
not know that if you don't have
right the right skill for it so there's
all sorts of stuff that you may never
see simply because you make choices and
sometimes you don't even know that it's
really a choice
fantastic game to them is only available
on the PC I want to talk a little bit
about some of the exclusives that came
out first of all on the Xbox one you
could have games like titanfall which
we've talked about but sunset overdrive
was a pretty interesting game when it
came out a couple of months ago as well
I know folks who were playing as you
know initial feedback from our reviewers
was not great it was like this game
seems like it's not that fun to explore
but once you got past that to era hump I
think that's pretty fantastic yeah
nothing else looks like it - I mean
you're flipping around everything is so
colorful and like that's sort of
aesthetic of like it's the end of the
world that everything's crazy I think
works really well know that style of
gameplay and you talked about Danny
about a titanfall you mentioned briefly
obviously that's a competitive
multiplayer stand up but we also had
Call of Duty advanced warfare that
you're doing a lot of cool stuff with
mobility in their competitive
multiplayer suite and the single-player
hours I mean talk about things like
Wolfenstein ya know if it would've
thought that that game would be as good
as a large man you know what I have tons
of people in my Twitter feed clearly
trying to tell me that Wolfenstein is
the best shooter of 2014 and you know
they might be right yeah that's not a
bad - I am it's right one of the games
that I actually thought was one of the
best shooters of the year it was grand
theft auto 5 weirdly enough who saw that
one coming first person and but yeah of
course you know we talked a lot about
big games here the small games of course
are eligible as well games like for
instance my we're all talking about our
sort of personal top fives I know I've
definitely got a transistor in there and
as well as common brawl which is a great
PC game that came out earlier this year
as well but one of the games that a lot
of the office has been playing is that
hearthstone oh yeah tons of hearthstone
players and I think the biggest argument
when we talked about hearthstone in
terms of its nomination was where we
play it more on the PC or on water you
know and it ended up making the nominee
list for both because the voices were so
loud in favor of that game because it's
so clever it's so engrossing and it's
just there's the the strategy ceiling on
it is so high you can be into this game
for hours
hours and hours yeah as some fantastic
games there's there anything else said
that's peeking Eddie you guys we haven't
mentioned it muster a shout out I think
two telltale okay so many games is here
because not only is the wolf among us on
my personal like it's one of my personal
top ten games is there a nominee for
best mobile yeah and but we've also had
great things like tales from the
borderlands who would've thought that
the best Borderlands game would be the
one with a fatality right or in the game
of thrones
of course Walking Dead Season 2 has been
hope it goes well like telltale you just
you do what you do you keep doing it
because we're eating it up yeah we have
the reason why we didn't put up the
video of all the nominees or the reason
why we're not talking about them all
here today is because there are simply
too many of them 2014 is been a great
year for video games and we are very
close to announcing GameSpot's game of
the year for this year in fact it'll be
next Thursday December 18th live 2 p.m.
Pacific right here in the lobby where
we'll be unveiling
conversing first of all about the
possible winners we think should have
one and then unveiling game spots game
of the year 2014 so make sure you put on
your calendar 2 p.m. Pacific right here
on GameSpot calm next Thursday December
18th we'll see you there